What is going on guys? Mr. Zinc here.
Welcome back to another trade review.
Today we're going to be covering the two
trades I had today for negative 340. I'm
trying to get this video out before Luca
goes and resets this loss because there
was an issue with the project X data
feed. Besides that, let's get into how I
analyze today. What we did into open,
what we did right, what we did wrong.
Just go over that. So the very first
thing that I noted was that we were
gapped up 1.5%. I will replay it back to
where we gapped at open. So you can see
that we were gapped up into open 1.5%
from Friday's close. That was because
the government was reopening. If we go
ahead and exit this replay,
the first trade that I went and took,
really the only two today, obviously I
only had two. The only trades I took
today, there we go, was a long targeting
up to the IB high. Now, if we go to the
trades I had on the day, I entered that
at 10:39. So, it was 9 minutes after the
IB was formed. That was right on this
1030 candle you see here. Now, we
almost, and the unfortunate part is this
was just a small one to one R trade.
This was $140 profit or $140 loss. We
were seven cents off of taking the IB
high.
Now going into the data and backtracking
to that 1.5% gap, this is where the bias
for the day came from. If we go to the
gat fill report on Q's and we note the
gap fill by size and then we go down
once this loads and go to gaps over 1.5%
since we were gapped up over that
amount. 100% of the time this gap has
not even filled to 50%.
So gaps of this size, really no
anticipation of having any downside.
That's what started the day's data. The
second point, and since we didn't have a
reaction at London 50, I couldn't trade
that. So we were just going off of data
today. There you go. You can see the
London 50 there. Going over to Q's on
the initial balance break and we go down
to the buy rejection report.
This tells us what the percent chance
for a break of the higher low is based
on which one forms first. We had the IB
low form first. So we have a 78.95%
chance of breaking the high, having the
first break of the IB high. That is why
I was targeting up to the IB high. We
missed it by seven cents and we ended up
going all the way down and hitting the
21% statistic. So only 21% of the time
when the IB low forms first on a Monday,
the low gets taken first.
Not only did we hit that statistic, we
go back to Edgeville and go to the
bystandard report. This shows us what
happens with a single break, double
break, no break of the IB.
We went and hit the bottom. So, we hit
the 21% statistic on the initial balance
breakout and then we came all the way
back up and broke the high, ended up
closing the day on a new high. That stat
for a double break is a 22% statistic.
So, not only did we hit a 21% odd today,
we also went and hit a 22% odd. The fact
that we hit both of them same day, I
believe that takes it to what? one in
five times one in five, one in 25,
whatever percent chance that comes out
to. All in all, not too upset with a
negative 340 day on a day like this
where we have a significant gap up. We
have a banking holiday tomorrow. We
managed to control the loss. Now, the
size of this candle that broke the low
of the IB $228. If we go over to Lucid,
go on the MNQ chart just to see the size
or point size of that candle. Zoom all
the way in here. That candle was 93
points. Now, if you're trading anything
more than probably 5 MNQ on that and
your stop loss is below the IV low,
that's a blown account and a half right
there. So, controlled the losses today,
stopped after two. I believe that after
two losses, there's not really any
reason to go and trade. The main reason
being
your third trade, you're just trying to
recover back to green. Now, again, I do
have I did have a blowup day on this
account October 30th. Thursdays just
aren't my thing. Monday, this is getting
wiped because Project X had some issues
with data feeds today. All in all, still
very happy the data that came out.
Everything lined up with why we should
be taking the IB high. We shouldn't have
been expecting any downside because this
gap fill has never happened with a 1.5%
gap up. Now, that was just for 6 months.
Uh if I go and do this report for let's
say five years on the gap fill,
go to gap fill report and we can go to
by size. It's going to take a minute to
load up here. uh gaps over 1.5%
over the past five years there has been
61 of them only 21% of those have filled
or that's 50% of the gap fill as well.
So if we go to custom go to 100% of the
gap gap fill
for the past five years gaps over 1.5%
only one out of every 10 fills. So
that's the odd that we had going into
open. Why we weren't expecting any
downside data lined up for upside, lined
up for the IB high breaking. Just one of
those days where you get a little
unlucky.
Thanks for tuning in for this trading
recap. Any questions, drop them in the
comments. I'll get another one of these
posted later this week. Peace out.